embryogenesis is the process of building
the human body from a single cell I
think it's one of the most incredible
things that exists on Earth from a
single embryo so how does this process
work yeah it is it is an incredible
process uh I think it's maybe the most
magical process there is and I think one
of the most fundamentally interesting
things about it is that it shows that
each of us takes the journey from
so-called just physics to mind right
because we all Start Life as a single uh
quiescent unfertilized oocyte and it's
basically a bag of chemicals and you
look at that you say okay this is
chemistry and physics and then nine
months and some years later you have an
organism with high level cognition and
preferences and inner life and so on and
what embryogenesis tells us is that that
transformation from physics to mind is
gradual it's smooth there is no special
place where you know a lightning bolt
says boom now you've gone from from
physics to True cognition that doesn't
happen and so we can see in this process
that the whole mystery you know the
biggest mystery of the the of the
universe basically how you get mind from
matter from just physics in quotes yeah
so where's the magic into the thing how
do we get from information coding DNA
and make physical reality out of that
information so one of the things that I
think is really important if we're going
to bring in DNA into this picture is to
think about the fact that what DNA
encodes is the hardware of Life DNA
contains the instructions for the kind
of micro level Hardware that every cell
gets to play with so all the proteins
all the signaling factors the ion
channels all the cool little pieces of
Hardware that sells out that's what's in
the DNA the rest of it is in so-called
generic laws and these are laws of
mathematics these are laws of
computation these are laws of of physics
of all all kinds of interesting things
that are not directly in the DNA and
that that process you know I think I
think the reason the reason I always put
just physics in quotes is because I
don't think there is such a thing as
just physics I think that thinking about
these things in binary categories like
this is physics this is true cognition
this is as if it's only faking other
these kinds of things I think that's
what gets us in trouble I think that we
really have to understand that it's a
Continuum and we have to work up the
scaling the laws of scaling and we can
and we can certainly talk about that
there's a lot of really interesting
thoughts to be had there so the physics
is deeply integrated with the
information so the DNA doesn't exist on
its own the DNA is a integrated as in
some sense in response to the the laws
of physics at every scale the laws
of the environment it exists in yeah the
environment and also the laws of the
Universe I mean the thing about the
thing about the the DNA is that it's um
once Evolution discovers a certain kind
of machine that if if the physical
implementation is appropriate it's sort
of uh and this is hard to talk about
because we don't have a good vocabulary
for this yet but it's a very kind of a
platonic notion that if the machine is
there it pulls down interesting uh
interesting things that you do not have
to evolve from scratch because the laws
of physics give it to you for free so
just as a really stupid example if
you're trying to evolve a particular
triangle you can evolve the first angle
and you evolve the second angle but you
don't need to evolve the third you know
what it is already now why do you know
that's that's a gift for free from
geometry in a particular space you know
what that angle has to be and if you
evolve an ion Channel which is Ion
channels are basically transistors right
they're voltage-gated current
conductances if you evolve that ION
channel you immediately get to use
things like truth tables you get logic
functions you don't have to evolve the
logic function you don't have to evolve
a truth table doesn't have to be in the
DNA it's you get it for free right and
the fact that if you have nand Gates you
can build anything you want you get that
for free all you have to evolve is that
that first step that first little
machine that that enables you to couple
to those laws and there's laws of
adhesion and and many other things and
this is all um that interplay between
the the hardware that's set up by the
genetics and the software that's paid
right the physiological software that
basically does all the computation and
the cognition and everything else is a
real interplay between the information
and the DNA and the laws of physics of
computation and so on